hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to darkwood
i am better now i was
going to pull a until dawn
and start completely over just to get
this point so that i could
make that happen however i i took a step
back
i reevaluated and i'm like okay you know
that's fine i didn't make it and that's
okay
all that matters is that i am having fun
with this game and this is my
playthrough
so i am going to see it through because
i honestly
don't know what that would have done i
think it would have led
sooner to the end of the game but
there's probably another way to end the
game
and whatever that way is is my way
so i gotta go back i don't know what to
wear but i have to go back
i did pretty good for my first time
through that thing
whatever that was okay so it's 15
49. i something about the floodgates
i'm not sure about that but something
about the floodgates
happened so that's a thing other than
that
i'm not a hundred percent sure i'm just
looking around a little bit
oh
good stuff um i could take the gas tank
i guess
that's the other thing like i would add
the playthrough get all the abilities
get all the items like it would have
taken me
hours to get back to where i am now and
i'm not gonna do
that ruin i found a ruin
i don't really have time to explore a
ruin or seems to be blocked yeah it does
but i don't see a way in
whatever ruin i don't know it's whatever
i don't have time
uh have i been here oh i found another
ruin
um i don't really okay
that's that's gonna be unpleasant
hmm i don't know why i feel like i need
to go in here
i no god i don't feel like okay i'm in
i'm in here now
i don't have time for this i do not have
time for this
oh god oh god what is oh oh god okay i'm
i
you know this was a mistake this was a
mistake i have to go i have to go thank
you
i have to go i have to go it is almost
time
and i have to go i found another ruin
there's many ruins here
many many ruins didn't i find this one
already oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god
oh god what the [ __ ] i blew up
i'm on fire no no no no no
no no no no no no
no all right well i don't have time to
go back
that's for sure great okay i gotta fill
up the generator probably
great that's great tonight is going to
suck tonight is going to very suck
hey buddy i gotta turn that on
i don't have any bear traps that's okay
i need molotovs hello
how you doing yo ow you okay
how you doing man i i have something for
you mister the boy picks an enormous rat
corpse from the ground and dangles it by
a tail
huge one isn't it i caught it this night
for you
i saw it sneaking by the wall i played
dead the best way i can play dead end
it this mouse i mean she jumped on my
hand and started nibbling on my finger
i quickly clasp my hand and bit through
its neck
i always do that that way they stop
running the corners of the boy's mouth
turn up in a grotesque smile
exposing rows of overgrown teeth which
even his mask couldn't hide
my mice are good better than bark and
these
funny black bugs here taste it
you'll like it i'll take it thanks hey
thank you
when i catch more i'll give them to you
thank you you're a good kid
so sad oh my god you're a good kid
please get back soon okay okay i'll uh
yeah yeah man i'll get i'll get back
soon
that's fine i gotta i gotta prep i have
no prep right now i have
nothing i i have a dead rat though so
that's that's good
can i eat that oh i'm regenerating
healthy hey those rats are pretty good
hey those rats are pretty pretty dece
all right gonna pull one there
and i'll put an explody bit right by it
so that i can shoot that and blast him
to hell
definitely gonna actually blast things
to hell this time
which would be great ah this is gonna
suck bigly i don't have molotovs
molotovs
oh my god i don't have oh i'm out of
rags
okay all right
oh god that was someone getting caught
that was someone getting caught wasn't
it oh god you're
not there were two of you apparently ah
where are you
yeah oh god many dogs
no dogs no dogs
okay oh god what is it what is it what
is it what is
is it a dog it's a dog is it a dog it's
a dog
okay it's just a dog it's just a dog i
can kill dogs melee style
i could go around and confront left my
stupid bear trap right there i don't
know if that's going to get in the way
good oh hi hello
yeah oh i missed i can freaking missed
oh my god i can't kill a dog i've
forgotten how to kill
okay there we go don't hit it okay we're
good
okay never mind not that way drink the
well well dry
okay thanks for using that up
hey i need rags thank you actually that
was very
no oh my god okay dead
rags more rags nope okay okay okay okay
okay
dodge i forgot how to dodge whompus
okay got him okay i
need bandage so many uh
little things coming at me which is
interesting a welcome change i guess
not really but okay i'm gonna put
another right here
put that close to it okay okay
we're fine this is all good because they
gave me rags
molotov molotov great oh
who's there who's there
oh god oh my god oh my god thank you for
the rag
thank you for the bottles i love that
thank you i love you
oh yeah i have potatoes i forgot i stole
all their potatoes
i'll have a victory potato i guess oh
yeah and these helpful lungs oh right
last minute arrivals how you doing music
man
music boy you okay glad you're back yeah
you know i i might have to leave you uh
for a lot of the day but i'll try to
come back
i guess you'll probably be safe i guess
i don't know i i'm not 100
sure oh
hey don't we're fine
we're all good we're all good
okay so i need to go get my crap back
first and foremost i think i can sell
that
i could make gas bottles and sell them i
don't really need to sell a lot more
because i they don't really have that
much to buy but
i will anyway okay that's about as good
as it's gonna get
uh i also need to go get my stuff so i
need to
save some space for it i will leave the
bandages behind
i'll bring the shuffle because you never
know what you're gonna dig up hello how
you doing
you good oh a ping pong ball
whoa the musician hums and bounces a
small ping-pong ball against the wall he
probably found it amongst the junk
suddenly he notices me oh it's you the
ball bounces off his deformed hand and
lands between my feet
give back the ball why would i why would
i take the
why would i take the ball why would i
take the ball away that's the only joy
he has
the boy clumsily grabs a ball in his
hand he carefully hides it under his
legs so that it doesn't roll away
oh my god that'd be so sad why would i
take the ball
what kind of cruel jerk am i i'm gonna
go get my stuff
i got a torch to burn away the crap in
those ruins i'm gonna explore those
ruins there and then
go to the cottage there was something
about the snail that i should explore
okay where where is it where is it right
there this is it this is where i died
no is this where i died this is not
where i died is it where i died
yes it's where i died who
where why what oh my god
everything wants to blow me up oh my god
oh it hurt my items to get blown oh
that's a different i have two
shovels how did i get two i don't know
whatever sure let's explore whatever the
hell
was in these ruins that was worth
getting blown up for
this is definitely good stuff that's
such
good stuff that i needed thank you
all this good stuff all right man
you know that's some good stuff the last
thing i need is more supplies
i don't know what's up with that one i'm
not sure what the deal is there
but i'm gonna kill it
ow okay all right i got it i got this i
got this
run and no actually let's do a quick hit
that's what the axe is about quick hits
yeah oh god oh i did it wasn't ready for
that one that's okay
it's okay
ready more oh god
and uh okay that's excellent that's
excellent that's exactly what we were
hoping for
and this is your demise
this is not worth it was it it's a
shovel
i have a shovel now there was also a
door here i could have gone in and
i have a shovel now hey music man
how you doing my fro ow my friend
my friend i'm glad that you're back
thanks
all right well anyway i don't know if
that actually did anything but i checked
in on you so
that's something i'm just gonna drop
some stuff
on the ground because i've got no other
place for it i don't know if it goes
away
when you drop it but i'm dropping it all
right i'm gonna go up to
uh the the the the the
the the place with the the the snail
oh god no no no no no no no not today
okay that's lovely that's great that's
good stuff
those are my favorite oh god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh my god what a waste of ammo
how you doing oh it is gone
oh it went away okay good you did you
really did just have to wait a day hello
oh
oh hello
map radio i already know that stick the
rags oh
notebook we have nothing to eat since
the flood i've caught some snails and
frogs
better this than nothing i'm out of the
crosswords i found last year in the old
wardrobe at the junkyard the only thing
that's left is to continue writing the
journal and listening to this strange
radio
in two days i will visit the junkyard
again maybe i'll finally find a tape
recorder or something that will allow me
to record this weird signal i feel that
there's some meaning hidden behind it
i'm hungry i'm eating grass or whatever
i can find in the water i've seen some
strange men between the trees
they're not locals they don't hide they
were dressed in strange clothes but i
was too far to take a better look
besides i'm alone and there were at
least three of them maybe i'm delusional
or maybe these old ruins aren't empty i
found a blank tape and a broken tape
recorder maybe i can fix it and do
something with it i've also found some
other useful things
i've written them down and left them for
later i don't have the strength to wear
them all on my back
is it possible the radio tower emits
this strange signal it's been a couple
of years since it's been turned over
the woods have blocked the way to it but
no other signal reaches this place from
outside
it must be that tower i need to take a
break from this radio i hear this voice
everywhere
strangely familiar i can't get it off my
head
okay oh good e
a lot of rusty radio equipment is
screwing on the floor old recorders and
destroyed tapes
everything is covered in goo dripping
from the leaky ceiling
a dry corpse overgrown with small roots
all right
what was the point of coming in here
there has to be something
you
you you are you her
hole okay well that was great
okay good stuff i guess i don't know
what was the point of all that
what was the point of that what did i do
all that for
well right right right what was that
damage organic quartz some kind of
organic corks are slowly pulsating they
are
surprisingly hard and durable all right
well that was weird um
don't know what what it's all about but
all right
i need to find an oxygen tank i know
that's like
a oh god
oh you're stuck you know what that's
good you know you're stuck
you shouldn't have done that yummy
dummy got dumbed on dummy dummy dummy
okay oh god no no no don't trust
okay he's gone
sure we're gonna go with the big ol
shure on that one
maybe there's another like junk pile
because i didn't go to
like the left side of the junkyard very
much
there's gotta be something junk pile yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes maybe i
shouldn't have
maybe i shouldn't have gotten rid of all
those other shovels it would have been
really handy
okay all right that's a thing
okay sure um uh you'll take the
bear traps well it's the same as scrap
metal i get i don't know
tubular magazine sure sure let's just go
with sure and let's get out of here
i'm gonna try to skate by the lake to
see if
it said something about the floodgates
so there might have been something down
there
is this the place yeah i oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh found something okay hello
hi no no no oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god
shoot it shoot it shoot it hit it
oh my god
oh my god i hate them the worst i found
an old shed
i found an old shed oh the flowers that
that's lovely okay hey how you doing in
here
they're running okay good i'm gonna eat
this bread good
good bread the floor is covered with
flowers of various colors
some are fresh some are mu some are more
some are more hello
oh come on
calm the frick on really i don't have
enough shovel for it because i used my
shovel
all right that's fine glowing eye there
that's
also fine and now it's raining that's
exactly what i was hoping for totally
fine i gotta go home oh there's another
hole i don't have enough i don't have
enough i need to bring all my shovels i
need to repair all my shovels and then
bring all my shovels
i just don't have enough right now not
enough i don't have enough
oh god i left my lights on
all night really stupid to turn it off
no turn it off
no turn off okay all right um
well here comes another night lovely how
you doing bud
hey how you doing i was worried you
wouldn't come back i am back
wouldn't leave you wouldn't leave you
behind no way
oh who's there
who's there oh hey ho oh you uh you
missed the if you missed the bomb the
mom the bomb the bomb the bomb the bomb
hit the bomb hit the boom
hey how you doing it's night time you
all right you keeping up hey it's a
little crazy out here
but uh don't you worry i've got it all
taken care of
all taken care of i don't have enough ah
molly that's why they invented molly
tops
oh no my potatoes my potatoes my potato
sash
well hey why don't you just fall over
okay why don't you my potatoes
what is trying to get through oh is it
the babies are they trying to get
through there
stupid babies stupid babies
ah oh missed one i missed all of them
oh god who the hell
do you think you are
i need you for armor armor light armor i
don't think i'll ever be able to make
heavy armor but okay oh my potatoes are
okay okay they're all good
oh what the frick
okay is that a note what
can only decipher individual words shell
thick goo
light okay shell thick
oh god okay
dead bug thanks oh god
are the is that what's happening they're
just in oh they are
oh i gotta clear the infestation oh i
see
oh i see yeah this is um unpleasant
oh god oh my god oh i'm not ready for
you right now
oh god oh god light it up light it up
good thing i had the gas there
oh my god that's just gonna spread for i
don't okay
molly there we go got it
thanks thanks for using a full what i
don't have another molotov
hang on hold hold hold the phone hold
the phone
okay what happened oh you're not
what i thought you were okay you are
so dead i think
i can't tell but i think you're dead
it's been a good night
good night for me good night for
everybody
[Music]
okay i made it another night i'll work
workbench upgrade
that's right i still can't find another
plier i need more pliers please
can you take these antlers this mush uh
i need your
everything okay cool thanks thanks man
oh you're gas that's right
in case i leave this stupid thing on
again which i probably will
okay i am almost out of
actually i am out of pistol ammo pretty
much i've got
shotgun though so i'm going to start oh
but i
oh if it's the mushroom dudes i'm just
go
i i'm going to keep my pistol but i'm
going to refrain from using it on
everything like i have been i'm going to
i'm going to only use it on what needs
to be used upon and i'm going to bring
my flares i don't know why but i think
i'm in
you know what actually i'm not going to
bring the flares i'm going to bring the
gas
and the matches which is a much better
way of dealing with goop and i'm
bringing all of my shovels
hey how you doing little guy i have a
delicious wee mouse for you i caught it
this night here you go
hey thanks i'm gonna eat it right now
yum
mega yum super duper yum
thank you i'm gonna go back down i need
to get to this old shed
all right let's just go for it oh here
we go
i just wanna dug this up before
friendly new stuff okay and running
pills which i like
now tell me the way to get in this house
is right here
key oh another one i don't think it's
any use
well good good is there something around
the back
good good maybe i gotta follow the
flowers actually that seems like a more
logical explanation follow the flowers
these are clearly leading somewhere
so i just follow them right right
oh hey i don't need it but that's good
to know
oh flowers
oh what's this
there's another building in here oh
interesting
gas tank probably useful actually i'll
take it you know
actually i'll take it bear trap i'll
leave it just in case something needs to
hit it i found the cottage
good a cottage surrounded by a barricade
made of old furniture and a lot of bear
traps
like a lot okay a lot of bear traps
lots of bear trappies a lot of bear i
gotta disarm this one
if i have to run out of here fast i i'm
well if i'm being chased actually i
think that'll be okay
a lot of a lot of mirror trips why do i
want to repair that
i don't have well i guess actually i
would if i just looted all these i could
repair it but why would i want to
that's the question that i have right
now i mean i'll do it just because it's
an option
and i don't know why it's an option but
this is weird
this is very weird okay i'm repairing it
and i actually have gas on me which is
very strange
okay hello
an intense smell of flowers fills the
air
okay lock need a key okay
do i have a key oh
thank you for fixing our generator you
can come in
what hello
oh hi oh
the elephants the air is filled with a
suffocating sweet odor or a rod
who are you the woman is wearing a heavy
ruined coat her voice is suppressed by
the cracked gas mask she's wearing
can't you speak did someone take away
your voice two children hide behind the
woman the younger one eyes me nervously
cowering in fear
the older one just stands there
emotionless you're not from around here
i would have recognized you we may keep
to ourselves but i know everyone here i
would never forget your mug
the younger child pierces me with its
eyes the steamed visor of its gas mask
betrays his rapid breath your gob looks
like that because of this finished air
you know
i bet you can't speak because you didn't
keep your mouth shut when walking
through the woods
the trees and plains are simply
beautiful here and the bushes bloom
gorgeously in this time of year
but don't let the charm of this land
deceive you the devil lurks between the
trees
and he gets to you through the mouse and
nose the older child's grasp on his
mother's hand tightens
he does not lift his gaze from one of
the hut's walls and
you're just gonna stand there i know you
want something you leopard demon
you're not getting anything from us i
don't trust you leper gob
you hear me i don't trust anyone who
breathes this filthy air
the woman stares at me intensely through
the cracked mask did you take
my marcinek was it you who kidnapped him
talk no that can't be
the woman stares at the floor her greasy
black hair drops down on her mask
it's impossible stupid child he went out
and he never came back
he was on about how his granny will take
him mushrooming i have no idea where he
i told him he can't go outside i told
him that the devil will take him
take off his mask and take him away i
would look for him but
she lowers her head even more as if
observing the dead flies stuck to her
coat
you want my trust bring my marsonic back
my stupid marcinek
find him and bring him home here's the
key to his room
he was spending a lot of time there
recently maybe you'll be able to find
something that'll lead him to him
okay a photo of three boys the woman
takes a photo and freezes
no i don't know who that is i remember
this road
the woods devoured it about three years
ago it used to lead to our village
i walked it to school the woman stares
into the photo hypnotized
road home my road home you're just like
these lunatics who roam around the woods
searching for god knows what there used
to be more of them
i guess most of them starve to death i
remember when they appeared not far from
here
must have been around two years ago
around two dozen of them they were led
by these three weirdos dressed in old
rags
they set up a camp at the marsh there
between the trees they watched our house
stared right in my windows the oddities
i thought they wanted to kidnap my
children
or harm them in some way but when the
night fell i lost sight of them there
was no one there in the morning
apart from these two here at marcinek
there's one more boy of mine
my precious darling a blessed child the
woman rests her hands on the oxygen
tanks of the children standing beside
her his love fills our tanks with clean
air
for this we are forever grateful to him
for the clean air for the oxygen tanks
for these beautiful masks and the book
in which the devil has revealed his true
image
along with his evil plan my son took it
away from the trees with his own hands
and brought it here to us something
exploded in the northern part of the
swamp
made the ground tremble devil know what
it is i see you're curious
investigated if you have a death wish i
think it happened in the junkyard the
youngest child hidden behind the woman's
back until now finally finds the courage
to make a small step towards me one
little bear ate a little soup
a faint little voice heard then one came
and
quiet the woman smacks the boy in the
back of his head the punches are the
hood of his rubber
cloak lands in his masks fiber not now
not in front of a stranger
alright so said something about a
grandma mushrooming right
something about a grandma mushrooming
and i think i got a key to
this room hello hi
how are you there i think someone used
it as a bed small bundle
map oh primitive map interesting
okay map oh anyway he said something
about
grandma mushrooming there's a mushroom
grandma
i know this i think in the mushroom
glade that's where
that would feel yeah so i'm gonna go to
the mushroom glade
they really are quite secure here i do
like it this is very good
uh sorry for taking all of your bear
traps all right anyway maybe i should
pull this
i i don't know if this does anything but
i just feel like i should
i have a funny feeling that i was
supposed to find this
a long time ago like this was supposed
to be one of the first things i found
and yet i didn't because i'm dumb wasn't
mushroom grandma here
wasn't she here was she not here
she might not have actually been here
damn
[Music]
where was she then she must she must the
circle is here
i'm in this it's like she's here
somewhere
oh my god woogie with guns you didn't
see
[ __ ] i saw them in the night all right
yeah okay
is this yeah this they're here yeah this
is yeah yeah yeah yeah this is my this
is mushroom grandma
this this is mushy grandma i found
everything in the wrong order
literally everything in the wrong order
absolutely
100 everything hey how you doing
mushroom granny
eat the i don't know i'm not gonna eat
the old lady
cigarette pack a torn empty pack of
cigarettes bring a fresh one next time
the woman examines the drawing on the
packaging is it our quarry
oh yes it's the one located in the
southeastern part of the swamp
the woman takes a photo into her hands
lovely boys
all they have left is their father okay
wait then
wait then oh pliers oh my oh wait key on
a key ring are three flowers etched on
the drawing
oh okay
what does that mean there's something to
that there's something in that
place there oh what the [ __ ] oh there's
like a back way out
or in or something maybe there's a way
to like go underneath
like some it may not look like it on its
surface but there's a way to go
underneath
yeah that looks that looks underneath
the ow so there might be
some kind of hidden passage
oh
so i shine the light and then i okay ro
ro row row row row like your life
depends on it
row i made it
i'm here ammo no ammo there's never ammo
okay but that's okay interesting then i
room
oh yes yes yes yes yes yes
oh no no no no no no no yes no
um
should have expected that all right
mushroom place mushroom
man yes oh it's
head ended up there great single shot
i already have one of those thank you uh
it's nothing i need
it's nothing i need god damn it damn it
but
i find whatever i got a pair of pliers
which i guess i needed but at the same
time
i guess i don't need it oh there
wouldn't have been a way to go in there
anyway
oh so that must still be ow
i'm an idiot okay we we have made
progress
let's go journal yeah journal finally
you want to see the granny about the
mushrooms the woman has given me the key
to her sons and perhaps i'll be able to
find something that will help me locate
the kid
so i'm i'm with the granny with the
mushrooms i did get a key
wait did i try the key with the key ring
on the oh
now i'm thinking i'm an idiot there's
footsteps all over the place here
or something mauled him not long it's
awfully thin
plus a piece of neatly cut stone is
covered in blood someone would probably
use this as a weapon
wait is this the kid and let me maybe
show the rock to granny
and then maybe try the key in here
none of my keys fit what about this rock
yes it's a stone you can probably find
some good ones here because of the
quarry nearby but the wards have surely
devoured it by now it was in the
southeastern part of the swamp
why are you showing me this i don't know
i don't
know let's try holes let's go holes
let's go holes while we still have a
little bit of time left let's go holes
i've been holes
oh what enter enter enter enter oh
what what
[Music]
oh thank you for the shortcut that would
have been
so good to know so long ago
ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho
ho ho ho ho
oh
oh god damn it yeah jeez
no room inventory that's fine all right
oh
god hello hi oh
i miss that i'm very dumb i needed that
apparently okay cool well got that
closer up can't have it's all exposed
well now that i got the new shortcut i
might just have time to go
talk to grandma and maybe show the
drawing oh my god i so
do not have time to do this oh my god
grandma grandma's a kid grandma grandma
grandma hi grandma hi yes
the old lady takes a drawing and squints
her eyes yes
you're his father or brother he came
here a few days ago
he was very nervous he hid in the corner
and stayed there for what must have been
a whole day
he relaxed in the end i think he likes
it here
i like when he's around too he enjoys
drawings although his
drawings are not very childlike the
moment casts a nervous look at the small
window overgrown with mushrooms
his force is not a place for children
nor old people
it's a place for the likes of you i saw
some villagers through the window
yesterday they were hiding
right there the woman raises her hand
with a great effort pointing to an
unspecified place with her trembling
finger
they were hiding but i have a keen eye
despite my
ears i saw their hungry hollow eyes
i know it's on their mind they want to
devour me me in my house
at first i thought you're one of them
but you seem like you can
control your uh appetite
get rid of these hungry mad men the old
woman lowers their voice to asylum
murmur
do a good deed son and get rid of them i
don't know where they live
they're young and strong you will manage
i'm sure you'll find some clues near my
house
if you make them go away and the child
will be safe
i would let him return home all right
great i
am so out of touch sorry i gotta run
grandma or i gotta kill some people
i think that must be in reference to the
villagers that are in the quarry so
not only did i steal their potatoes i'm
gonna steal their souls
i'm pretty sure that's what these weird
ghosts were talking about
which is totally normal very very normal
that whatever that is i know i must
return to my hideout i'm aware of this
good thing there's a convenient hole you
mind if i use your hole
awesome thanks man how you doing buddy
you all right i was worried you wouldn't
come back i'm here man wouldn't leave
you
sorry i didn't close your door yeah i
know you want your privacy
uh upgrade yes whatever that can do
oh that's it oh [ __ ] but i can make the
pump action
oh hey oh hey
look who's got a pumpy action
oh what's that oh yeah it's me
i have the pumpy action i left the
generator on all day
again i love that it's such a quirky
thing about myself
i have no gas i'm so quirky
just gonna put this here oh but i need
the pistol to shoot that okay
you know what actually i like the idea
of having multiple weapons
maybe it's for the best that i didn't
accomplish that thing because if that
was like a shortcut to the ending
then there was tons of stuff that i was
gonna miss
oh no oh no oh okay
time to test out the new shotgun oh
that's painful
come on add me come at me come on at me
come at me on me
i'm just gonna do this hello
oh wait hand hey is there someone there
is someone there oh is someone
uh there ah
did i get him did i get him oh i didn't
get him i didn't kill him
i guess i'm not terribly surprised wait
where'd he go
where is he hello oh no i'm helpless i'm
helpless i'm helpless out in the middle
of the night
oh i hope no one comes and gets me
god i hope no one comes oh oh
oh oh god oh
no oh god oh no
oops uh the range just not a thing on
this
oh dead straight up
i turned off the generator now so i
don't forget
[Music]
okay easy night okay so i survived that
night
i think that the next one might be the
last episode if not i will
probably just make it an extra long one
and get to the end
it's not that i'm trying to rush it it's
just that like i want to see the end now
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
you